ils représentent 13% de la population
mondiale ce sont des pays dits riches
comme les états unis le royaume uni le
japon ou encore certains états de
l'union européenne et la moitié des
futurs doses de vaccin contre le coc u19
leur appartiennent déjà c'est ce que
pointe du doigt un rapport publié cette
semaine par les ong oxfam
oxfam a analysé les accords que les
sociétés pharmaceutiques et les
producteurs de vaccins ont déjà conclu
avec des pays du monde entier concernant
les cinq principaux vaccin candidat
actuellement en phase iii d'essais
cliniques sur la base des données
collectées par air finity des accords
d'approvisionnement déjà été conclus
pour 5 303 milliards de doses dont 2,728
milliards 51 % ont été achetés par des
pays développés parmi lesquels le
royaume-uni les etats-unis l'australie
hong kong et macao le japon la suisse et
israël ainsi que l'union européenne
toujours selon les ong les 49% de doses
de vaccins restants auraient déjà été
promis à des pays en voie de
développement comme l'inde le brésil ou
encore la chine
résultat de nombreux pays ne pourront
pas vacciner leur population avant un
certain temps même dans le cas
extrêmement improbable où les cinq
vaccin s'avérait efficace
près des deux tiers 61 % de la
population mondiale n'auront pas de
vaccin avant au moins 2000 22 des
difficultés d'approvisionnement et ce
alors qu'un dispositif baptisé kovacs a
été lancé cet été sous la supervision de
l' oms 172 pays se sont à la base
engagés dans ce programme conçu le site
pour garantir un accès équitable au
vaccin mais la course au vaccin semble
avoir eu raison des bonnes intentions
c'est ce qu'indique la directrice de
campagne de médecins sans frontières à
nos confrères de l'express
c'était magnifique tout le monde était
prêt à s'engager à mettre de l'argent et
puis assez vite si ce n'est en même
temps cela a dérapé
certains pays ont commencé à signer des
deals en direct avec les laboratoires
ce qui fragilise tout le système l'union
européenne par exemple aurait au moins
acheté 1,5 milliard de doses selon un
décompte de la fp quand les etats unis
eux pourraient réserver un total de 800
lyon de doses auprès de six fabricants
face à ce constat nombreux sont ceux qui
dénoncent un nationalisme vaccinale
c'est le cas par exemple de la
présidente de la commission européenne
qui a récemment plaidé pour une union
européenne de la santé
mais malgré les rappels à l'ordre
certains pays semblent bien décidés à
affronter la crise du coc vie 19 en
ordre dispersé au risque de pénaliser
une nouvelle fois les pays les plus
défavorisés